the Trump administration meanwhile
blasting China for its handling of the
outbreak President Trump saying Beijing
made a huge mistake as you just heard
trying to cover up the crisis Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo also ripping China
for suppressing important information
we've seen the fact that they kicked two
journalists out we saw the fact that
those who were trying to report on this
medical professionals inside of China
were silenced they shut down reporting
all the kind of things that
authoritarian regimes do it's the way
God made his party's opera this is
classic communist disinformation effort
that created enormous risk
let's bring in Fox News contributor
Byron York he is also the chief
political correspondent for the
Washington Examiner he joins us now
Byron good morning to you
so we'll get to the president's reaction
last night in just a moment but first
Mike Pompeo blasting China in that
brand-new interview well remember
Pompeyo is a former CIA director so he
knows intelligence he knows Chinese
tactics not only in the virus but in
years past so this is something that he
has some expertise to talk about US
officials apparently now believe that
China hid or destroyed evidence to keep
the severity of this crisis a secret
from the the world this is something
that US officials have noticed for a
while
a senator not too long ago told me that
back in January he was noticing the
discrepancy between Chinese government
public statements everything's fine
nothing to see here
and the increasingly draconian efforts
they were taking to contain the virus in
Wuhan that may you know his is his
eyebrows go up and and be suspicious of
what was going on so US officials have
been looking at something funky going on
in China for quite a while
interesting what was your takeaway then
from the president's words last night as
you just heard him say he believes that
China made a huge mistake and he has in
the past vowed retaliation what does
that tell you about the u.s. next move
when it comes to China well first of all
the idea is is not that it was done
deliberately it was not created as a
bio-weapon or something like that but
that china was studying this virus in
part apparently to show that it had a
world-class biology capability and that
by accident it got out of the laboratory
so the question is what does the united
states do now the president has had a
very delicate relationship with China
over his entire presidency as he tries
to get increased and better for the US
trade terms with China there are obvious
things to do I mean the United States
has funded the virology lab in Wuhan
maybe that's not a great idea certainly
members of Congress are a lot of members
of Congress who want to stop doing that
so I think there'll be a number of
actions the the administration will take
they may be kind of ascending actions
starting slow and if China does not fix
things or come clean
perhaps they become more serious in
members of Congress stepping forward
with some ideas as well senator Ted Cruz
of Texas talking about the some of the
bills that he's bringing forward to
combat China here's the senator this
week I've got four pieces of legislation
I'm introducing one of them is
legislation that prohibits the u.s.
government from conducting any business
over any telecom or Internet
infrastructure that china owns or
controls why because they use it to
steal that is part of their strategy
it's a bottom line Byron for the
American people sitting at home they
hear the president in that Town Hall
last night talking about a huge mistake
that led to all this on the part of
China
Pompeyo calling it classic communist
disinformation effort the American
people want to know if China will
ultimately be held accountable final
thoughts well as senator Cruz just said
there are a number of members of
Congress who want to do that not clear
what the president will do I mean
there's there's so many different public
concerns about this obviously the first
concern is the health of the American
people and stopping the spread of the
virus the second concern is reopening
the economy I would have to say
the you know taking action against China
is probably the third concern but
absolutely necessary once we find out
what actually happened byron york always
good to talk to you thanks for kicking
off our monday morning show Thank You
Sandra